so in the next few minutes I want to
make a case to why you ought to go on a
media detox and cleanse your mind your
soul your spirit with all the garbage
media's fed us the last three four
months but before doing so I want to
share with you a tweet I tweeted this
out a couple of days ago and I said
first the media used COBIT 19 to scare
the hell out of us so we would stay home
cost 45 million people their jobs many
businesses out of business
stats are saying 50 percent of
restaurants are not gonna open up again
trillions of dollars of stimulus costs
and taxpayers money so we got scared to
use Cobra 19 then asked open 19 started
slowing down cases the next thing they
did is they use the tragic event to
divide America and everybody were like
debating oh you can't say that so you
can't say no black but you can all lives
well you can't say some like that boom
everybody clashes and they're happy
because they're getting more eyeballs so
phase number one was used cope in
nineteen for us to stay home phase
number two is use a tragic event to
divide America what's face number three
use this tragic event and go support
your cause and protest protest you ought
to go do it and people went out to
protesting what happened to social
distancing and then when everything
calmed down right after they told
everybody to protest then they said oh
oh oh there's a spike coming up and
people got to be very careful because
walk watch with a video there's a stay
home you should stay home now you
shouldn't go out wait a minute you just
told me to protest now you want me to
stay home matter of fact here's the
tweet by NBC News shows you the
hypocrisy the hypocrisy of media this is
two hours a part of a tweet that went
out
so first NBC News sends out a tweet
saying rally for black trans lives draw
packed crowd to Brooklyn Museum Plaza
and you see tens of thousands of people
lined up and they're protesting and NBC
News is fully endorsed in it right
two hours later President Trump plans to
rally his supporters next Saturday for
the first time since most of the country
was shuttered by coronavirus but health
experts are questioning that decision
are you kidding me to out the level of
hypocrisy two hours apart first you're
supporting a protesting then you're
saying no because it doesn't match your
narrative so are you really
because when I look at the definition of
journalism there's three things
journalists have to do one is a
verification meaning data correct data
that you give that there is some
credence behind the data you're not just
making this stuff up number two is
independence meaning you're not imposing
your opinions you're an independent
opinion
here's we're stating the facts this is
what's going on and unless if you're
wrong you're held accountable that's
what they call themselves as journalists
those three things number one it's not
about data today number two there is no
independent today it's I'm giving you my
opinion now last but not least where is
the accountability who's who's gotten
fired lately you tell me the last
journalist that got fired these
so-called journalists today are at best
activists some of them are clowns some
of them are puppets and some of them are
purely entertainers now let me not make
everybody be in that side because
there's a lot of them that are good but
most of them today are not journalists
anymore so why am i sharing this with
you here's what I'm sharing this with
you why have a media detox listen I've
been on a media detox for good for weeks
I don't watch the news when I go home
anymore I don't turn on CNN I don't turn
on Fox I don't every single time I read
stuff I no longer watch this stuff
because they're gonna sell me their
emotions on what I need to be doing I
don't do it I get stuff that I get on
social media because I'm on our on a
daily basis I'm not doing nothing
related with TV and this is why here's
why you ought to make this consideration
for yourself look in my business I have
a lot of issues that I face meaning
people come up and get a lot of
different problems I run a company we
have attorneys lawyers challenges cases
clients many different things in a
financial industry and typically anybody
that has a conflict with another person
when this person comes to me here's what
they always say they always say what
this person did wrong they don't say
what they did wrong they always start
off with you know what he did here's
what he did he said this he said that
Eric oh my gosh no way yes that's what
he said that's what he said that's crazy
and I used to let first get rattled
because the jury brought what this
person said okay then this person comes
what do you think they say do you know
what they did this person said this and
they said this and they said this now
you're getting rattled couples come up
to you don't say let me tell you what my
husband did here's what my husband did
here's what my husband did oh and then
the wife come
let me take my wife did here's what my
wife did there's always only the
argument that validates their argument
what the other person did wrong to
validate your argument that's exactly
what media is doing our kids do this to
their parents all the time you will not
believe what my brother did what did you
do yesterday I'm talking to my son
and I get a letter from school from one
of his teachers and this you know he was
kicking people all day at school so I
said so tell me what happened yesterday
nothing yeah I thought you kicked the
kid in school did you kick somebody in
school no I don't remember you don't
remember no I don't remember I see you
know what I don't remember what don't
you remember I said I don't remember
that about your leg Oh to give you you
know you remembered you bought the Lego
yesterday I said you went to school
yesterday what do you mean you don't
remember why you kicked this kick I said
if you forgot why you kicked the kid a
kid I forgot why I bought the Lego for
you then he says I just remembered I
said what did you just remind and then
he tells me the story the media has
turned into my six-year-old son that's
what they're doing they're only giving
you the story that makes their argument
stronger not the whole thing they will
literally if the video plays for men and
20 seconds tells the whole story
they will only play 37 seconds but it's
the 37 seconds that validates that
argument it's not journalism that's
called entertainment 90% of all
journalists must step down and become
pundits you know what's the difference
between a journalist and a pundit here's
the difference
a journalist reports they verify okay
they're independent here is that here's
a date on both sides you make the
decision for yourself and they're held
accountable if they screwed up yesterday
reporting we did was wrong and if
somebody screws up too much they get
fired when's the last time somebody got
[ __ ] the only reason journalists are
getting fired is because of sexual
harassment not because of what they did
wrong you don't see a lot of journalist
getting fired at MSNBC CNN or Fox when's
the last time somebody got fired I don't
see it why there is ZERO accountability
now I also don't have a problem out of
these journalists in you know honestly I
am NOT a journalist I'm a pundit I will
come on the other end and work for CNN
Fox and MSNBC and I just want to give
you my opinion on what's going on with
the current situation but I'm no longer
a journalist because quite frankly I
can't do it anymore
now I'll respect the media but as of
today journalists are not journalists
they're entertainers
activists puppets and clowns at its best
90% of them there's some of them that
are doing a good job and they are
dividing America in ways that words
cannot describe my suggestion to you go
on a media detox maybe don't do it for a
month try for a week for one week tell
yourself I'm not watching any news I
will read only but for one month I'm not
watching any news and if you're in for
this challenge to go on a media detox go
on Twitter tweet at me use the hashtag
media detox or go on Instagram and don't
even hand use my handle just put I'm
going on a media detox and challenge
your friends and peers to go on it with
you and watch what happens to your
spirit how it cleanses of the agitation
the frustration that you're experiencing
because quite frankly somebody called me
in Hollywood who say a good name he
doesn't have all the money at in
Hollywood but he told me says I am
afraid to share my real opinions because
I'm gonna get crushed
I said go make your money first make
your money many of your watching this
runner getting caught up in all these
issues that are going on the marketplace
and your bank accounts only 73 thousand
dollars your bank accounts only $22,000
go make your money so then you can say
whatever you want is saying don't let
these media people distract the hell out
of you where your dreams don't become a
reality and all their dreams are
becoming a reality they go to fancy
restaurants they go to fancy parties
they go all these other places they go
take their one-month vacation around the
world how about you how about it
happening to you you're their customer
they're not your customer make them your
customer that's where you ought to be
doing that's how I think about this
myself so again my challenge to you if
you have the courage if you have the
courage and I've made my case to you
where you said patent make some sense go
on a media detox and watch what happens
one week later if you're committed to
that comment below I'm willing to go on
a media detox for one week
having said that have a great week
everybody
you